[Music]
Halle Berry makes her relationship
Instagram official never dare a girl
like me to do anything because I just
you know challenge rumors have been
swirling about the 51 year old stunner
under 35 year old beau music producer
Alex to kid ever since last month after
they were reportedly spotted out and
about in LA now she's setting the record
straight sharing this adorable black and
white shot on Instagram Tuesday with the
caption my balance this is everything
right now so just who is Holly's new
love interest a source tells eg the
British music producer is a very chill
guy and soft-spoken
he's low-key and a really nice guy and
according to another source
Alex's skills are legit he's worked with
Rihanna imagine dragons and many others
superstar singers quote he's incredibly
artistic creative and serious about what
he does he's legitimately a great and
solid guy with his own successful career
the source even gives Haley and Alex
their seal of approval saying it seems
like this is a great match Oscar here
comes my real Award
[Music]